[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
July 14th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
a lot of airlines promote a co-branded
credit card that offers an assortment of
benefits that can help cut your travel
expenses Wall Street Journal travel
reporter Jacob Passey joins us to
discuss pitfalls that consumers and
travelers should watch for before
signing up so Jacob Airline cards offer
different types of benefits but what
kinds of perks are typically standard
across all Airline carts so most of
these cards will give you perks like
waiving fees on checked bags giving you
priority boarding when you're getting on
the plane and most of them come with a
benefit of allowing you to accumulate
either miles or points that you can then
use to book reward travel later on and
that kind of accumulates as you spend
money with a credit card the exact rate
it accumulates varies from card to card
and they all usually come with sign up
bonuses so when you first open the card
there's going to be that offer of like
60 000 miles or something like that if
you spend a certain amount of money in
the first few months all right so let's
dig a little deeper into what someone
should consider in an airline card let's
say somebody has frequent flyer mile
status with a particular Airline how
could that affect their decision to sign
up for a credit card tied to that
Airline so if you have frequent flyer
status with an airline there are pros
and cons to having a card the pro would
be that with most carriers they now have
it that you can earn qualifying points
towards your status with the airline by
spending on their credit cards some
Airlines have it such that you could
qualify to certain tiers of status
without ever flying with them just by
virtue of spending with their credit
card alone the flip side of that though
is a lot of these benefits that come
with the cards are things that you get
from being a tiered member with a
frequent flyer program anyway so when
you get to the higher levels of status
with an airline you generally get
priority boarding you generally get free
checked bags and so these
perks that come with the card are kind
of redundant and when you think about
again the fact that you're paying for an
annual fee if you're not getting any
extra perks out of it then what's the
point but what if somebody or a family
only flies a few times a year so that's
where these cards can make a lot of
sense actually so let's say you're a
family of four you maybe go down to
Florida to visit the grandparents once
or twice a year but you're otherwise not
flying that often it's going to be hard
for you to earn frequent flyer status
but having the card will give you some
of those perks so the free check bags
alone for your family of four by virtue
of having the card could counteract that
annual fee you probably don't have
enough status to get into the lounges if
you want to relax in the airport for
that one or two vacations you take a
year but the card could get you access
to the lounge so those are the ways in
which the benefits can make a lot of
sense for a traveler in your reporting
you mentioned people who might live near
an airline's hub
and how that might work into the way
that they would select an airline credit
card how would it factor in there so I
spoke with one traveler in particular
she lives in Washington DC flies out of
DCA pretty often and that's a hub for
American Airlines and so chances are
when she's wanting to fly somewhere it's
going to end up being a flight with
American and so for her it makes a lot
of sense to have an American Airlines
credit card even if she's not going to
earn up to the levels of status to get
the like super crazy benefits still
having that card will just make her life
easier it allows her to have free check
bags so she doesn't have to worry about
cramming everything into a carry-on and
fighting for overhead bin space she
usually gets priority boarding so if you
live near a hub having that Airlines
credit card you're gonna get more bang
for your buck there we've had people on
from your reporting team before talking
about how accumulated miles don't go as
far as they used to
what exactly does that mean and how of
those numbers and why are those numbers
changed so for starters a lot of folks
accumulated a glut of points or miles
depending on the program during the
pandemic everyone was still spending
money with their credit cards but they
weren't traveling now obviously during
the past couple years we've seen a
travel boom and so folks have worked
through some of those points and miles
but there's still a lot out there and so
for that reason alone Airlines have
opted to devalue how far a point or mile
goes in many cases so that they are not
losing revenue and also because of the
travel boom they're not having to do a
lot of work to get folks on their planes
and so if the choices between someone
booking with points or someone paying
for a fair
they'll want to skew in the latter
Direction and so that's yet another
reason to make it so that you have to
spend more points or miles to book that
transatlantic flight and what kind of
planning do people need to do with their
travel budget if they want to book a
trip with points or miles
so given that that they devalue over
time don't sit on them for too long as
much as a lot of us want to hoard those
points and miles for that bucket list
trip to I don't know the Maldives with
the luxury flights and the luxury
accommodations those points and Miles
aren't going to be worth as much a year
from now so you're better off spending
them now will they ever expire they
generally don't expire so you don't need
to worry about them going away it's more
of an opportunity cost what's the
biggest mistake that you see people make
when managing their points of their
miles they forget to account for the
extra fees and so when you're booking
with points and miles it's easy to think
of it as free travel but in reality you
still have to pay taxes you still have
to pay fees so when you're talking about
for instance a transatlantic flight to
London if you're flying in business
class because you got all those points
and miles and you're splurging those
fees can add up quite significantly I've
heard folks say they can add up to
hundreds or thousands of dollars so what
you think might be a free trip could end
up actually costing you that's Wall
Street Journal travel reporter Jacob
Hassey and that's it for your money
briefing this week our producer is
Ariana ospreu our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris zinsley I'm your host
J.R Whalen thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
[Music]
foreign